[Music]
good afternoon everyone
again hello thank you so much for coming
today
to today's panel discussion called no
turning
back my name is valentina donchevich
from design studio of alternative
and on behalf of paper space asia i'm
delighted to be your host
for today's conversation which looks at
how
new ways of working will shape the
future planning paradigms
energy and blueprint of singapore's
cityscape there is also growing momentum
for the singapore government
and companies alike to tackle climate
change
with a nationwide movement to advance
the country's national agenda
on sustainability i would also like to
say a big thank you to our online
audience
we had over 150 attendees
registered online thank you so much for
being with us today
today panel discussion is the fourth
that we have put together together in
conjunction
with the exhibition that's taking place
downstairs at level 1 of national design
center that is
currently taking place until day after
tomorrow
this thursday this was put together by
paper space asia with support of design
singapore council we also would like to
say a big thanks
to our big sponsors wilcon
steel steels case exto and
lockspace they are also part of the
national design
center's casting hope program lineup
for april and may this year
now i'm extremely extremely happy to
and present to you our panelists for
today
chow mei group director for conservative
conservation
and urban design at the ura
urban redevelopment authority who is
also a registered architect with the
board of architects
next we are very privileged to have jung
young kim
cluster president of schneider electric
in
singapore malaysia and brunei who brings
over
20 years of international experience
in the automotive and lighting sector
we welcome our third panelist for today
richard payne whom our live audience
will see
on this projector screen owing to some
unforeseen circumstances richard joined
us
virtually today and we're very grateful
for the
technological support we have which
enables us
to actually converse with him despite
the distance
richard is the managing director of land
lease with over
28 years of property industry experience
he now leads an exciting new mixed-use
development
at pyala bar quarter in singapore
today's panel is moderated by marcus liu
ceo of savile singapore who brings a
wealth of experience in the real estate
industry i will now hand it over to
marcus to kick off the session
please help me welcoming our panelists
for today
thank you
[Applause]
well thank you valentino uh it is
very rare or not very often we have
events like this
where we would have a representative
from the government sector
we have an energy solutions provider and
then we have
views from a global infrastructure and
real estate developer
in land lease so this this
will be a a collective session
of a robust dialogue i would encourage
people who have darwin live audience to
raise any questions which will take the
questions at the end of the session
um today's topic is
very controversial to some extent of the
title
no turning back a lot of companies a lot
of experts have already given their
views
you have read a lot of reports from
third party providers in terms of in
terms of what needs to be done
on how you work how you live and
sustainability issues
so today's session just drills deeper
into some of those core issues that
we've been dealing with
and hopefully out of this session we are
a little bit wiser a little bit smarter
in terms of how we can take this forward
so without further ado
let's jump straight right into the first
question
for may if i may ask
is this last 18 months has
upended a lot of people's lives
not just at work at home
from ura's perspective
what has been a major transformation
for the organization
thanks marcus i think uh the last year
has been uh yeah many changes for so
many of us
i think from a ura's perspective i think
we've seen many shifts in activity
patterns across so many different
sectors
when we talk about telecommuting that's
become so much more prevalent
compared to pre-covert e-commerce has
taken up
food deliveries as well i think we've
also seen many of us
go out and enjoy the outdoors and in
fact i hear from many people that
bicycles are out of stock
so i think all these changes will have a
very big impact
on land use needs and demands
so while it's been a year of disruption
i think as
planners we also see this as a very
exciting
and fascinating time it's almost offered
us
almost like a we have a window to the
future and giving us
an opportunity to rethink we imagine
how we will live how we'll work who will
commute
and be entertained and how all these
aspects will become even more
intertwined
in the future so i'll say the biggest
takeaway for us
is actually the unpredictability
of what the future will hold and that we
will actually have to be
a lot more flexible and nimble in the
way we plan for the future
thank you may that's a good start good
start
uh yuan if there is one thing as far as
transformation in your industry what
would that be
yeah thank you marcus uh in fact we are
privileged to be in singapore because as
you saw i i
hold accountability as well in malaysia
and brunei and of course
there are different countries in the
different circumstances and singapore
has been
very privileged in that that aspect
nevertheless
if you see the office environment today
uh schneider electric
it has been very interesting journey
and learning every day because uh
working virtually as well as physically
in the office the combination of both
and using the right and proper tool has
been very challenging
uh in one side of course still we can
you know share
contents technology and evolve in our
projects and progress
in our evolution of the journey but in
the same time
in the eq aspect the teamwork the
harmony
and sometimes sense of belonging has
been a very
difficult element for the team so of
course
we try to use as much as possible to
make it effective as a team using a
virtual
environment as well as physical in the
office
making sure that we are in the within
the guideline of the government
not occupying more than 50 of our office
having the proper
social distancing as well as every day
we have been looking into how to improve
the office environment to attract the
employees back to the office as well
and how to of course consequently uh
interact better with our customers and
partners
thank you now richard you've heard what
uh eun had to say
um do you share the similar sentiments
yeah yeah totally i mean i think there's
a lot of commonality the only thing i'd
add for ourselves as a developer and
operator of
assets is we have to be extremely agile
through this period because of all the
change that's occurred with all the
regulations and when you're managing
people
and you've got a lot of people at the
coalface you've got to be yeah you've
got to be adaptive to all of that change
but you know zooming out of that detail
i think you know similar to the other
panelists it is a great time to reflect
and i think for ourselves and certainly
for me in terms of my personal time
we've invested a lot actually in
technology and
and and invested in platforms
to really uh allow us to come out of
this period with
a really good set of embedded um
practices and processes you know backed
by you know good i idea
backbone to uh to help us really improve
our productivity so
that's been a good thing i think through
this period
thank you richard just staying
on land list for a while
release has developed a very successful
mixed development up at pioneer labor
it's called
labor quartus now it's a massive project
it's gained a lot of recognition now
that this pandemic has happened
if you were to rewind things what would
be
stuff that you would newly implement in
today's new work environment
like what would you change
yeah it's a good good question i i and
and i think
fortunately we've rightly or wrongly we
got some of that we've got most of the
basics right i think
interestingly enough being a
decentralized development has been
beneficial
um you know not being sort of subject to
people being afraid of
densely crowded public transport and all
that sort of stuff
i think we've got good touchless entry
which has been great
in the way people arrive at work we've
got good air filtration
um and we've got a relatively high
proportion of flex solutions in our
office
around sort of 15 percent which i think
is going to grow
in its demand going forward i guess what
would we have done differently
um i always cringe when i look now at
when you
enter into our office environments and
our retail environments and we've got
these sort of temporary sort of setups
for
temperature control and managing people
as they scan and it really detracts from
the experience to be honest with you
and i think the reflection there is that
you know i guess we sort of thought they
were all going to be sort of temporary
but
the longer this goes on really you've
got to have permanent solutions for
these
um you know going forward so we'll need
to integrate that
in a better way um and i then think
within the
office environment um
you know we need to reconfigure the
office environment to make it more
suitable for how we work now um you know
it's quite quite difficult when you're
in an open plan office to get on video
conferences if there's a lot of people
doing that
it's actually quite disruptive and so we
need to be more accommodative
in in our designs now to um
to to reflect and and to accommodate
this different way of working
right and c-suites has been hugely
successful the last two three years
since implementation
can you share a bit more about that
yes assist with yeah growing moving
forward
yes so seasweets was really sort of
bringing a corporate
a corporate user focus into a co-working
environment so c-suites is flexible
working for
uh 50 people and above so we've got
quite large tenancies but want to
exploit that sort of shared working
arrangements and but have a very sort of
presentable and
high spec arrangement and yes uh
we're sort of fully leased which is
which is terrific
um it's been good and we now need to
as i was just mentioning now we now need
to give that a few
tweaks like i guess for the future you
know roll out of future c-suites
locations
to really accommodate a different way of
working and specifically
around people doing video conferencing
and
um providing you know suitable
facilities for that to be done in a
shared environment
right right i mean clearly there is a
demand of employees
working from home or close to their home
so i suppose this next question is for
me
um as far as master planning is
concerned
in the real estate industry there has
been an increase
enquiries for good quality officers
class a developments mixed developments
at the fringe of cbd
which also goes into the government's
tone of reducing carbon footprint et
cetera et cetera
uh but in recent years there hasn't been
a lot of
good development examples to even talk
about i mean you've got metropolis
there's one on the west end
and then you've got plq on the east end
but
apart from that there isn't much to
discuss
you know there is a demand but there's a
lack of supply in that fringe
zone so what would qris thoughts be
are you holding back from not releasing
more land in those areas so
well i think we're a little bit more
ambitious we're thinking beyond fringe
to maybe
you know further to our gateways to the
north to the east to the west
i think in a way um a lot of our
planning fundamentals hasn't shifted
even pre-covered to now and in fact
maybe covet has accelerated that push a
little bit more
and i think we're on the right track
we've been talking about adapting
a more polycentric development model
creating a more decentralized kind of
work cluster arrangements across the
island
and within the cbd trying to
increase the mix of users as well i
think with the onset of covert in the
last year
with a lot more people working from home
we are beginning to see that in the
suburban malls we have very healthy
visitorship
and then in the cbd it's been much much
quieter
i think this has really helped to
reinforce the importance
of creating mixed-use sustainable
proofings
we think that uh you know where people
can live and work and do everything they
need in one place
whether it's in the poly centers or in
the cbd
and we'll really like to continue that
push
so i think um what we're doing now is
within the poly centers
trying to further enhance the range of
offerings
to make it convenient for people um when
it comes to amenities
and conveniences but also work options
more people working from home
and people finding that they can work
anywhere right it's not just home or
office
i think we're beginning to see different
type of places
evolving to become more places as well
new cafes and we've seen co-working
spaces even in the
shopping centers and i think hopefully
with some of the companies also thinking
of creating satellite offices
in some of the areas outside the city
that this can give that polycentric
model
a bit more of that push i mean that
would definitely be
music to the years of some of the
developers who have dialed in you know
they're all anticipating for more
opportunities for for land sales at the
fringe of cbd
well i think with there's always
opportunities i think we've always been
uh
pushing for jurong you know with uh with
um
made available some parcels and
woodlands so i think we're really going
beyond the fringe
the developers are always looking at
fringe because this is convenient right
but
let's take it you know let's be bolder
we want to talk about reducing the
impact on transport and all that i think
there is a lot of opportunities if you
look at singapore as a whole
singapore's really not very big right
east to west it's
um half an hour by car
now coming to you you spoke briefly
about
some of the technology that you have
implemented
implemented you deal with a vast array
of clientele and
we are looking for technology upgrades
so if you have to talk about some of the
stuff or some of the
some of the the expectations the demand
from your clients
in schneider electrics implementation so
what were some of the
the stuff that you've done yeah i think
it's uh in in a
in a consumer-based point of view we all
face the technology and digital
coming to our lives uh much faster than
what we expected right
if you see who is not using the video
system uh
video meeting system and so on right and
that's similarly to the
to the you know developers as well as
the landlord
they have been using uh technology and
digital
as a tool to enhance uh and and give as
a premium
uh to the end user i mean sometimes to
the tenant or sometimes to the user
itself
employees or or people who is occupying
occupants of of the building so when i
see them there are many technologies
nowadays that make
uh much more easier and as well as safer
and reliable in the sense of building uh
and
as well comfort level so i'll give one
of the example one of the examples is
what we call the workplace advisor where
just not control the temperature the
lighting system
and noise but control the co2 level in
the certain
space of the meeting rooms or certain
ambient
where without oxygen or high level of
co2
you will not be as efficient as or
at least you will feel sometimes after
lunch you'll be tired and sleepy right
and this is the things that the facility
management team can look into the
certain space
and give a better space better ambience
and and better
meeting rooms as well to be interacting
and interacting
and integrating as well as performing so
this is some of the things that i see
more
and more of the technology and digital
usage
by the landlords and developers as well
as tenants and the users
that's that's a good segue into you've
spoken a lot about technology
but all this comes at a cost
so a lot of
industrial peers have ambitions
to implement such infrastructure but
there's this elephant in the room
that says okay it's gonna cost me x
amount of dollars what is my roi
so you are energy solutions provider how
do you address that
because we have developers darling so
look i want to go green
i want to embark on the government's
agenda to
sustainability reduce carbon footprint
but it's just costing us too much money
where do we begin so you have a slew of
technology applications how do you
overcome that how do you address that
yeah the cost issue yeah it's a very
interesting question because of course
this is a question for all of us
whenever there is
investment in place right uh is about
roi
uh how rri can be uh and and return can
be sometimes
tangible returns and sometimes can be
intangible returns
and those intangible returns can be you
know uh productivity of your your
employees or satisfaction
engagement commitment and many things
relate to that
so uh yeah return on investment is a big
question uh
the there are two two points that i
would like to
like to maybe uh share one is the axis
of
how you make the easy investment so
there are many companies nowadays is
coming with the
instead of capex model is coming with
the opex model
so the model that allows you to not have
the huge investment
and do like a subscription yeah similar
to
many telecom companies mobile
smartphones that you have been you know
experiencing before as a consumer
and the other axis is of course depends
on your ambition and goal
if your ambition is to give a
sustainable as well
as a good environment for your employees
uh you have to pay for that right so
not only uh saving energy and having the
pay back itself
but there are other elements that allow
you to
give benefits for your stakeholders and
that's the way
how we look into and in the sustainable
journey where we look into the
digital when we look into the solutions
and softwares
that allow you to have certain payback
and certain payback that might be
intangible but is still
sustainable and contributing not only
for the stakeholders
to the society and to the government as
well okay
and richard do you share some of you
sentiments on that like i mean i'm sure
lenny's is a
is a leader as far as reducing carbon
footprint is concerned i don't know
which year you're supposed to be
neutrality is it 20 30
uh totally uh net
total zero carbon by 2040
and uh scored one and two by 2025
yep okay yeah and what would landis
be doing well yeah so i think um just a
couple of points i think on the on the
technology
it is actually extremely difficult to
put forward your business cases
sometimes about the technology
investment and get a payback and
sometimes there needs to be a leap of
faith
we we tend to put forward our
investment propositions as a bit of a
hypothesis
if we spent this we believe we could do
x
and and see the gains there
understanding that those gains aren't
necessarily certain
but that's the way we're approaching it
and as you get more data and you can
triangulate that data
um you know you think you you certainly
think you can go and chase some
some gains so even for us on plq
which is a platinum you know a green
mark building
very high efficiency we're still chasing
uh further gains through that that
triangulation of data
and you know as a team where we've put a
target of chasing another four hundred
000 of operational savings
uh by using technology platforms to
drive greater efficiency so it's not
insignificant um and you know we may not
get there but if we get to 300 000 it's
still
still a fantastic result yeah
i mean speaking of sustainability not
just from
developers perspective do you share the
sentiments that increasingly there are a
lot of end users
who are also subscribing the same
thought same methods
so what is your view on that
yeah i think for the end users um
i i still think there's quite a bit of
education
are required around sustainability in
the terminology
and what it all means
and i think that with that education um
there will be greater awareness and
understanding
and when there's great awareness and
understanding then i think
that will lead to greater demand and
greater expectation
that the officers that we work in the
residential homes that we purchase have
to have
you know good and responsible
environmental outcomes
um so i think the first thing there is
really about education and awareness
and um just getting all the terminology
i don't know about the other panelists
or the or the audience
but there's a lot of terminology out
there right now and
you know some of it's overlapping and um
can be quite confusing
so you know i think if we can pull all
that together
then we can move forward thanks richard
i mean i guess
end users need not be just corporate
entities right
and end users can also be people staying
in their homes
now we've got this drive of of employees
now
minimum expectation to spend a certain
amount of hours at home
on flexible and agile work arrangements
now clearly
in order to drive towards sustainability
on one hand
you have carbon footprint reduction
in core cbd because people are working
from home right but now there's carbon
footprint increase
in where people are staying so from the
government's perspective
ura from may i'm calling missy ryan
how do you how do you feel i mean i'm
sure from a master planner's perspective
say gee
you know you're looking at the whole
macro perspective where
more and more people are turning on
their power at home even during day time
you know and using air conditioning
turning on the fans
so from from your perspective how do you
think that should set
policy changes
well i must say i i don't really know
the signs because
that's not really in my area and we
haven't been we're not in the business
of calculating energy spent in the cbd
versus energy spent at home
but i think that's really just looking
at it from one perspective
i think there's also huge energy savings
in the past year
um from telecommuting
because of the huge reduction in
transport
and i think that's just within singapore
if you look at that globally if you look
at you know
reduction in international travel as
well
and because we've gotten so used to
digital communication i think the way we
travel
and the need to travel will will shift
quite fundamentally going forward as
well whether it's for work or for
meetings etc i think um nothing replaces
face-to-face interaction i'm glad we're
all here today but i think we also find
that there's a lot of convenience
you know and time savings and i guess
carbon savings as well that can be
gotten you know from reductions in
telecommuting
uh not reductions in cultural limiting
reductions in
traveling well on the topic of that
um i guess the minister
indrani had a dialogue session
with developers with radars
and fellow agencies and
and she propositioned
the idea for developers
to start thinking on repurposing
their assets in core cbd because now
there's a big shift right
so and based on
some of the the my experience speaking
with some of these developers
they feel that there is insufficient
incentives
to change say an
office complex to residential or hotel
because the development charges are
too high of course the development
charge is determined by the chief valuer
but you are a is the administrator
do you have any uh thoughts or views on
that
i mean as much as developers want to
change it but it's just not worthwhile
because the roi isn't there
i think the idea of shifting
you know what the cbd is is something
that i think we have been pursuing for
some time now
both from uh sustainability
self-sufficiency
kind of perspective and also to create a
more vibrant
environment to attract talent and
visitorship so i think the
aspiration to move our cbd from
something that has traditionally
been a bit more mono used to something
that's been a bit more mixed use is
something that i think gets
embraced by cities globally and the
pandemic i think has really shifted us
in this direction
so prior to covet we did come up with
some incentives
the incentives are intended to encourage
conversion of some of the older office
buildings
into residences or the mix of users with
the intention to really bring in
life after hours and also during the
weekends
and we think that a mixed use precinct
will really be good to
sustain and support the neighborhood as
we can see from covet
a lot of the shops in the cbd really
suffered from the lack of a
living population and while the cbd has
been quite
much quieter compared to some of the
other suburban areas
even within the cbd there are quieter
areas and less quiet areas
so you compare like tanjong pagar to
raffles place for example
tanjong pagar because there is living
population in residences
you do see a lot more life you know in
the city
even in the past year and um
that is something i think we would like
to see much more of
in the cpt so with incentive scheme
i think there's always a range of
different developments in the market
different ages different mix of users
and at the end of the day it really has
to make business sense
right to the individual property
developers whether they would like to
take this on or not
but i think we have been quite pleased
to see quite healthy interests
from a number of developers and yeah we
do have ongoing discussions
um with some of them to talk about you
know how we can make use of it
um to repurpose some of these buildings
into multi-experiential places
i think that's quite exciting because i
think apart from the mix of users that
we think we're gonna get
it's also about maybe reimagining the
typology of your typical office
buildings
today a lot of them are podium power
quite inward-looking with very little
engagement with the street
because the city was very much planned
for cars
so we're also hoping that through the
rejuvenation of some of the older
properties
we begin to see a new property a new
kind of typology
with every development proposal there is
opportunity to open up the ground floor
and provide new open spaces a more
walkable environment
with more active users and frontages
that connect with the streets and the
spaces
to engender a much more you know
people-friendly community-centric
workable precinct that will endear
itself to
people both as a place for walk and
place i think that's that's
really our aspiration i must say that
a lot of the government agencies have
been very forthcoming and very engaging
with the private sector so that's very
very promising and it's very good
would you also say that that's your
experience dealing with some of the
agencies because i knew
i know you deal with the government
quite a fair bit yeah i think his
government has been very serious
especially with this new green plan 2030
as well
and i do see clearly incentivization
uh in in monetary base as well as
uh support base to make sure that we
have
uh proper and balanced uh sustainable
uh evolution in the in the city and the
country
so yeah my my my relation and
my discussion on on the topic related to
sustainability
uh is very clear supported by the
government and
uh i can tell i was uh four years
plus five years out of the country and
just came back recently
and the topic of sustainability and this
is a totally different
aspect compared to five years ago
when in the in the global perspective
singapore was not taking
that element of sustainability as one of
the
important point in the agenda now is
very clear is number one point in the
agenda
and you can see this in all the ministry
working in the similar direction so
for me is uh is a very uh good to see
this
and technology-wise solution-wise we
want to contribute to this
this sustainable uh journey right
and i was very impressed when you
mentioned
that your hq facility out in cullen
will be carbon neutral
in august this year yes how how how did
you achieve that
yeah so our uh using your own technique
yeah i think
so is just give you the the reference
the building is about uh
uh it's 30 years old building uh was a
noel building in the past
is in the kind of a warehouse industrial
zone
where we've innovated all of them in the
last three four years ago
and with all the technology in place we
were able to bring this
building as bca platinum certified in
2019 and then now in the q3 of this year
we'll go into the carbon neutral
and early next year we are targeting to
go to the super low energy building
certification as well and of course all
this is part of journey so
uh actually uh me was asking me if it's
just you know one
one key turn but actually is several
steps for sure
uh and uh one thing that i want to share
is that
even brownfield not only greenfield that
means
old buildings uh buildings that is
already existent
is able to become sustainable able to
become
uh green so it's not all doom and gloom
there is hope
yes okay now speaking of the green plan
you mentioned the green plan so richard
i mean i say as a developer
what do you hope to see in the green
planet what do you hope
for the government to put in detail for
industrial players like yourself
well i think i think the plan's
excellent i mean you know why i made the
comment there about how far all of the
government agencies have come and
when you look at the high level green
plan it's very comprehensive
and personally i'm very excited by it
what i would like to see um you know in
in that next level of detail is a bit of
simplicity i guess in how it plays out
um as much sort of inter-agency
coordination
as possible and of course i would be
remiss if i didn't say some financial
assistance from the government to help
pump prime things i mean
as a developer i feel like that's an
obligation that i must fulfill
in saying that but um all jokes aside i
i'm looking forward to it i you know the
plan's
very comprehensive it's it's you know
it's cutting across so many different
sort of sectors and um you know 2030 is
not that far away um so bring it on
yeah coming back to you
i know you do speak to a lot of uh
people in the government sector
you've probably laid down your wish list
in terms of what you want to see in the
green plane or ideally like to see
what would those be wow that's a
good question and thanks for
yeah it is i think it's a it's it's
all journey as as richard said as well i
mean we have all the targets
every company has and to be honest uh
this is not journey of
uh one company or another company
because we have this green plan
commitment which is called one two three
when you go to the scope threes
basically all the vendors that want to
be
supplying to the companies that's green
needs to be as well green
right in in a very simple in simple
terms
so i think the the government agenda is
very clear um
and i think is my wish list is that we
just pursue
what we are driving today of achieving
2030 in a more sustainable city more
sustainable
country which has a lot of angles of
course it's not the only building there
are a lot of other elements as well as
immobility and so on
so i i wish that we can continue this
journey together
and that needs uh government that needs
of the
private sector but of course as well
individuals so it's
all combination of these three major
pillars to make sure there's uh this is
a successful
journey yes i do agree i mean from from
my perspective
i think what richard has earlier
mentioned about
all jokes a psych i think there has to
be a robust financial scheme
where developers could tap on
not free money but a robust financial
scheme and an incentive
to hit certain kpis and hurdles on
achieving
net neutrality on on carbon emissions
and hopefully with a more integrated
alliance within the agency departments
where there could be synergies derived
from that
to achieve what richard said the 2030
goals
you know one of one of the the questions
that were raised
in our earlier discussions and this is a
question for me
and it goes back to people working from
home
and i'm sure you have had your
experiences likewise for yourselves and
the people on the floor
as much as people like employees like to
work from home
and some of the apartments are actually
not conducive for people to work in
you know some are working out from what
they call the shoebox apartments
you know or they are living with their
parents or they've got their dogs
barking
so from uh from a master planner's
perspective
um do you feel that there is a a
thrust or a need for you for the master
planner to put some guidelines for
developers
on restrictions on limiting the size of
apartments
that's an interesting question and a
question that i think we do ask
ourselves time
from time to time i think as a
policy maker for us it's always you know
a balance
between deciding how much to regulate
and how much to leave
to the market and i think with the
shoebox
kind of developments that you've alluded
to i think it's really a
function of both price and demand
um i think when it first came to the
market um
we were quite surprised at how much
people willing to pay for
you know not very big unit but i think
size is also relative if you compare
the size department here to size in hong
kong
people will think that you know maybe
shoebox is not so small after all right
so it's relative and it's uh i guess a
lot of
to do as a function of people's um
i guess preferences what they can to
some extent how much they can afford as
well
so i think in the past we have started
to find some regulations
outside of the city when uh not so much
you know to kind of shape here
um to try to
regulate the market but because we were
starting to see that
when a plot of land that is planned for
x number of units suddenly
doubled in size or double the number of
units it does have an impact on the
local residential community and to the
traffic as well
so i think some guidelines were then put
in place um
to to guide an average kind of uh
unit size um
but you know coming back to your
question on
uh current work arrangements and whether
that will give rise to bigger
apartments that's an interesting
question and uh
something that we'll definitely like to
see evolve as to whether or not we
should regulate um maybe i should ask
richard
my preference would be for less
regulation please
[Laughter]
yeah i think i think the market the
market will dictate i think i think a
lot of
you know recent launches i've seen you
know they've got
quite flexible spaces now emerging in a
lot of the apartment
um configurations for just you know
home studies and things like that and i
think
you know the shared facilities that a
lot of residential developments have
may morph to include shared facilities
for working as well
um so i think these will naturally form
themselves
and purchasers can make those decisions
about how important they are
for them and um and and use their
spending power accordingly but i think
it will change i mean i think
as we were mentioning before you know
there was a sort of sense when when
covert first came that
okay we've got a year of this and it's
going to go away i think there's now
more of a slump shoulders that we're in
for the long haul here and that we
we may need solutions for the longer
term and if it's not covered it's going
to be something else down the track so
yeah i think there will be there will be
changes um and
you know hopefully uh the development
community and
the government with hdb housing will
facilitate those changes
for the users yeah absolutely if i may
add on i think
we are starting to see you know more
interesting hybrids of interest for more
hybrid type of
developments that will allow for work
and
live at the same time i mean despite the
intrusion that we don't really like in
our lives
i think that's going to give rise to
very creative solutions and new products
in the market
and i think it links back to one of the
things i talked about earlier
being flexible and adaptable
to be able to accommodate some of these
new trends and that'll be quite exciting
okay i mean this is a good segue to one
of the questions
from a virtual online audience
and it sort of relates to the other
question that i had
but it's all well and good talking about
the private residential site
so this is a question from from the
online
audience with with the question is with
increasing
overlaps of what the home serves
family social time home office and
potentially health care
public housing needs to be able to
handle these demands in terms of
unit sizing the current trend seems to
be the opposite
with smaller and smaller public housing
units
can uraray provide some insight on this
short answer ura is not equals to hgb
um no i don't really have an answer but
i think um
you know we we we have very unique
constraints
in singapore we are an island city-state
um
you know not very big very scarce
land resources one of the things we've
done quite well
i would like to think is in the way we
have tried to balance the use of land
and also the way we have pursued
high-density living
but still you know providing for a very
livable
environment in the in the space of the
public realm whether it's provision of
amenities parks open spaces
that's been very well appreciated
uh by people as well you know during
this covert period both for
respite and recreation so at the end of
the day i think it's for balance
i think it's also about
always trying to stay relevant to the
needs of the
you know changing population so
what we have today is an evolution of
you know
various lifestyle changes and and
and demands
um but i'm sure you know with shifting
arrangements
in the way we live and work we may see
new typologies evolve as well in the
future
okay okay thank you me now this other
question again from an online audience
it's uh it's for richard and
yoon like in your experience or your
work processes
what do you feel are the biggest forces
working against you in achieving your
sustainability goals
what are the challenges apart from
financial assistance i've heard richard
said that really
yeah do you want to go first cheat yeah
research okay thank you
so so in fact uh
when i see the challenge uh i'm looking
into the perspective of the whole
stakeholders not only schneider itself
right
uh i think is the biggest challenge that
uh
maybe you said already on a part of that
but is the investment
right it's how to invest in technology
and how to get the payback
and this is especially when you are in a
in the
in the corporate environment right is
not individual right
sometimes for individuals because of
your well-being you might invest in
technology that you want to
benefit in the well-being sometimes you
don't really think of your
roi right at home i think is everybody
as their family not everything is roi
right uh but of course as company you
need some roi
uh explanation and uh
that i think is the biggest challenge uh
that's why we we see
a lot of movements as well the companies
going from the k
packs to opex and when i maybe uh
explaining a little bit more on the
capex to opex is that
you know any investment is done in a way
that you don't have the full investment
in t0
time zero and then basically you pay
subscription you pay
monthly basis alone certain periods of
time it can be
a few years it can be you know 10 years
depending on the on the
on the equipment as well as the
technology so
that's i think is the way to enable uh
some of the difficulties to overcome the
the major obstacle which is the
investment part
aside that i mean if you see
depending on the country there are
countries that is sustainability is not
in the agenda of the country yet
and of course that is very difficult but
whenever is in the agenda of the country
then i don't see many obstacles i think
it's just about the speed
of the journey how fast or how
slow we go into the journey depending on
the resources depending on the incentive
depending on the mindset and the culture
of the population as well so you feel
that we're going to get there somehow
it's just in between there may be
hurdles sure and so
to impede that trajectory surely okay
surely
richard do you feel the same way yeah
look i'm very optimistic about
you know sort of moving forward but you
know in terms of the the question and
the
challenges um it's always around
financial challenges
and coming up against you know
individuals be they being your
investment committee or if they're you
know investors who
just want to look at things through the
lens of the financial return
and sometimes can't project themselves
um
you know five or ten years down the
track to to understand
a relevancy discussion or a financial
implication discussion or where the
market may be
and that can be quite that can be quite
a challenge
um if you want to get approvals and you
want to get things done
so that's the biggest thing for me uh is
is trying to pitch the story and to try
and
pitch what we're doing now as the
solution to where you want to be
in a future world um yeah
thanks richard without neglecting the
audience
in the room i would like to ask if
anyone has any
question that they would like to ask the
experts here
there's a mic that will
go around some if there's any questions
from the floor
if you could identify yourself and you
know yeah hi i'm uh duncan i work for a
company called concourse and we
specialize in
project managing the design and fit out
of
primarily retail and f b spaces but also
sometimes uh workplace um we were a
workplace yesterday and we were
we were brought in because we were very
much involved in
sustainable fit out but also end of life
and um i guess it's a question to
richard and you marcus
as you manage uh office spaces and so on
uh at the end of life uh
typically with workplace the landlord
demands that
everything is reinstated right back down
to
the force lab the ceilings um
all the furnitures everything's removed
and
we were at this uh workplace yesterday
um we were brought in to see if we could
salvage some of the
materials before they they end up in
landfill
and it's quite shocking to see how much
stuff is going to landfill
like we're talking hundreds of desks
hundreds of chairs
beautiful marble that's been put in
there has only been there for
five years and so on um and also
all the electronic waste and everything
all of it's going to landfill
um and so if we're looking at
redesigning the workplace in a time of
change
is that something that is being
considered
maybe from from your clients but also um
from from richard's uh point of view
yeah yeah i'll go first this time why
why i'm keen to go on this one
first well firstly duncan i
totally agree um and
uh completely on the same page with just
how
wasteful that is and um
particularly with the shorter leases
here in singapore a lot of the leases
are signed for
you know three five years and you know
it's a very short cycle for
materials to be thrown out so for us
we you know we see the solution to that
is
co co-working options
so the product that we have which is
c-suites really you're providing a fit
out
that can be reused by many tenants over
an extended period
and getting a far more usable life
out of the facilities that you provide
together with sharing the facilities of
meeting rooms and function rooms
which is a much more efficient solution
because a lot of the things that are
built in the first place the utilization
rates are extremely low
so the counter to it and where we sort
of see the future is maybe in in
flexible
environments um and len leases voted
with their feet there so we're
we're a sub-tenant within c-suite so our
head office is now
just a tendency within c-suites and when
we leave
c-suites one day and go to maybe another
c-suites location
that fit out will remain for for others
to then move in
and we can get much higher utilization
rate so
that's a very important path for
sustain you know sustainable outcomes as
far as i'm concerned is to minimize
exactly what you've articulated yeah
well duncan thank you for the question i
totally agree with
you with what you said and i must add
that that landlord must really dislike
that fade out
for you
in the last 20 years singapore
developers and landlords have been very
very stringent
because the space may suit one company
may not suit the other
so it's not fit for purpose for the
other group that's coming in
so more often than not you see landlords
taking the easy way out
maybe not easy way or the wrong term to
use but they're more convenient
way is to have the tenant reinstated to
bear condition
you are right in the sense that uh
there's a lot of wastage that's going on
that's why in the last i would say last
five to eight years
there's this change in mindset and
mentality not all landlords
but increasingly we are witnessing an
increasing number of
landlords who are prepared to accept
uh a fully fitted office and they will
market it on that basis
so it's still not across the board yet
so we've come from a stage where it used
to be
none you have to really bring it down to
bare shell
so we have we're now at the stage where
we can consider
to probably moving forward to yeah no
problem
you know as long it's uh very usable i
will continue to market it for you
but sure you have to retain a certain
reinstatement some it could be a reduced
sum
but there is this dialogue that's
ongoing so i think that's an evolution
of the whole process
and moving forward i think there'll be
more of that especially when landlords
are
increasingly um like richard i mean
himself
are pressured uh internally and by
external factors
to put in place the right regime
on fit out when it comes to meeting um
carbon emissions zero carbon emissions
targets
so perhaps maybe uh from landley's
perspective in the fit up manual
you know they may prescribe certain
things that needs to be done then this
has to be recycled that has to be
recycled
sure it will cost more but i'm going to
take talking about the point on cost
right so i think everybody has to play
their part
the developer has to pay it apart
hopefully government agency can provide
some financial assistance
and i think the end user also must play
their part in contributing
to that cost element so that the whole
ecosystem can thrive
so any questions from the floor
again please state your name and your
organization please
my name is stephen louis um perpetual
student
um i appreciate some of the insight that
the speaker has given us in terms of
what is happening in this environment
but i'd like to push that further and to
do so allow me to just to set up the
question
we can look back and see some of the
changes that the industrial revolutions
had caused in terms of disruption
and construction so in the first
industrial revolution we had steam
and the second one we had electric the
third was the internet
and now we are in the midst of the
fourth industrial revolution the
nanotechnology
in each cases jobs and lives have been
totally disrupted and wiped out
but replaced by other jobs so for
example
um the horse and carriage people who
tended them
were gone in place of automobiles
orchestra players musicians in theaters
were gone
in place of movies that had sound
so in looking at our current industrial
revolution
we can see now some of the changes
that's been made
so at changi terminal 4 for example
schneider had put in smart technologies
with kiosks
replacing actual people to check you in
so under the heading of no turning back
and forthing ahead are there others
jobs that you can foresee that's on your
tables that you haven't yet divulged to
us
that we can anticipate and see because
there is no turning back
that's a very big question maybe to me
okay
yeah i i of course i am not expert to
to share all the potential jobs that
might create
i can see in my environment uh actually
new jobs that has been created
and the importance of the jobs that has
been uh
you know uh popped up
in in many many aspects uh not only in
singapore but
globally so of course we are going to
the digital journey
and in digital journey and a lot of
need and demand on the software
engineers
application engineers so we see
a lot of jobs related to that angle
as you might see every day i mean in
singapore very clear you see a lot of uh
gaming companies as well right so you
see
more and more people into how you create
the software how you create the game
as well as how you digitalize things
then you need to create uh expertise
in that area and then of course all
these
digital for digital is not just for
digital sake of digital
but it's about data so how you manage
the data
uh and then of course we can talk about
data storage but as well
as the data intelligence artificial
intelligence of the data so
all this journey that i see even in our
company in the journey of the
digitalization
we see jobs going into that direction
rather than
simple engineer which is electrical
engineer
that has been our base of the
fundamental uh
you know job capacity that we have the
majority of the team
uh but nowadays more and more software
that's what i
see uh in our journey i just like to
take yoon's point a bit further
i mean stephen that's a great question
it's been asked quite a number of times
where technology has replaced
manpower and i think on the question of
sustainability and no turning back
a classic example would be
the job subsidy scheme that the
government has provided i mean
billions of dollars right over the
course of 12 months
and and those funds
were utilized to help sustain businesses
and keep employees gainfully employed
but if i may add i mean since may it's
here
that perhaps the government could have
also thought about
utilizing some of those funds to create
a new industry
because it's all well and good talking
about
infrastructure implementation and
technology
but you need to create a whole new
industry hiring people
to upgrade lift systems we're just not
talking about high skilled stuff right
even the low end
we need to employ mechanics not just
engineers
to implement and install
virtual facial recognition uh
uh uh modules in in in commercial
complexes
or shopping malls so so this
thrust and this momentum to achieving
sustainability goes
and in advance of technology i don't
feel it's going to eliminate jobs
i think with the right application it's
going to create more jobs
i think both the government and the
private sector just needs to
identify where the gaps are and apply it
correctly
if i may add i saw one of the video
was for a question similar question to
bill gates and one and buffett
and they were doing a seminar and
workshop at the
university of columbia new york and the
question was
what you would do if you are young again
right and there are there are pillars
that he mentioned very clearly there are
three pillars one
is biotechnology
and the other one is about artificial
intelligence
and the third one is about energy those
are the three things that
will have a lot of demand in the world
and they would do something similar in
that category
so maybe try to answer your
part of your question
well um it's uh now past 5 pm
we will be extending the session to 5 30
for both the life and the virtual
audience
please feel free to stay on if you'd
like to join us please keep your
questions coming
there is another online question
and that is for may and yoon
uh how do you think singapore is doing
in terms of energy consumption
very technical
where are we right now in comparison to
where we
should be in the next five years
there are three questions here so i'll
just stop at question number two
okay so one first question how are we
doing
as a country in terms of energy
consumption
um where are we right now and and
what do we hope to achieve in five years
maybe two i'm going to defer to you
i have to admit that i'm not really an
expert yes i mean you are energy
solutions provider
the tip of your fingertips energy
consumption yeah
and i'll just say i agree
[Laughter]
i can't talk about megawatts uh
gigawatts but
i think the most important thing is uh
yeah is the consumption
of energy today i mean as
in singapore um has been of course
many of the part has been imported is
not
resourced from their own country so we
know we all know we have this energy
dependency right so
there are people asking the question why
we don't put all the solar
in the whole singapore and then we don't
have to buy an edge anymore but
in fact even if we have the all solar
panels in the whole
surface of singapore we might not get to
the
level that we are using today maybe in
the future
i don't know but today most probably not
so so this is uh
uh of course the balance of the supply
and demand that we have in singapore
and i think the journey of the green
plan is very clear
uh we want to reduce our level of
consumption
is not only bringing the renewable
energy
as maybe we are talking about solar but
as well
a lot of things relate to hydrogen as
well as nuclear i think those are the
three
axes of investigation uh but
is is is beyond that i mean one is the
source but it's about
the usage and as we are going today i
mean the
the trend it shows that we're gonna use
more and more energy
right so basically that's why we have to
go into the plateau level first
and to enable us to start to decrease as
well
so that's the journey until 2030. so
reduction-wise uh i think is every every
uh
everybody knows in the green plan very
clearly uh i think
everybody in the company wise corporate
wise they have a different targets and
different commitments
for instance in our case we have a
commitment to reduce 50
very clearly as a country of course we
would not be able to reduce 50
so that i think is the journey where we
are in uh so in one side is the
contribution of
the source the the energy matrix how you
work with the energy matrix and the
other one
is about how we use in a more
smart way intelligent way and efficient
way i think that is the two journey that
we have
thank you i hope i answered the question
without numbers and
now before we take that next question
online i just want to check whether
there's any other
questions from the live audience
no okay that's uh
this question is just beeping in my face
so i have to ask this question
so moving forward i mean we all know
that we are now into phase two
okay on the topic of no turning back
and this is a question for both richard
and newton
the government has reversed to phase two
encouraging no more than fifty percent
back in the office
some employees prefer to work from home
one hundred percent of the time
and few people prefer to have flexible
work arrangements in the office
full-time how can organizations like
yours resolve the current dilemma
with an empty office environment due to
a leasing period
as part of the opex which many sectors
are finding
challenging now so you practically have
an
empty office you know if you were to
allow your staff or provide full
flexibility
you know i have five years left in my
lease what am i going to do with it
so maybe richard you want to take a stab
at that
sure i i can talk maybe from personal
experience as i
um i think we've probably all gone
through
shifts in our own thinking
around the new ways of working
personally
you know it was very disruptive to start
working from home we started to learn
about the new
technology and then once we got used to
that uh we actually
sort of thought actually it's not too
bad you know when you began to think
maybe i'm actually more productive
working this way and then as time went
on
and you got lonelier and lonelier and
craved more
sort of human contact and the
opportunity was to then go back to the
the office certainly for myself i was
very energized by that
getting back seeing my colleagues
bumping into them
and i found that whole process of
getting back into the office
very energizing and just reminding
myself of why i actually like going into
the office and
and interacting with with people um
and this latest sort of reversion back
to phase two is a bit of a blow to be
honest with you because it's sort of
like you saw a little bit of the future
but uh it was then taken away but
look my take is that there is a lot of
inertia in us
all um when things change and we get
used to the new circumstances and then
we go okay that's great
but then we start to reminisce about
things that we used to like and
look i think the future will be one
where um
every company will be different um and
countries will be different but maybe in
the singapore circumstance i think we've
learned to look to live
and work flexibly and to the extent that
um employers phys you know
are okay with that flexibility i think
we all will
find a new way of working you know that
suits
our own personal circumstance if we've
got children and
all those other complications in life um
you know for
you know where i think things are
polarizing for ourselves len lease
is probably three days in the office and
and potentially two days at home but you
know there will be a degree of
discretion for
for our staff and higher on a high level
of trust
um but i think that's probably where
we'll end up
um but i certainly don't think the
office is is dead by any
any stretch of the imagination and i
think it'll probably come back quite
strongly
as people remind themselves what they
you know what they really enjoy about
working in teams and within groups and
interacting and all of those casual
bump hims that we have with people that
we haven't seen for quite a while
yeah yeah richard i mean uh thanks for
that
i couldn't agree more um
as far as the the solutions are
concerned because there is no
one-size-fits-all policy
it varies from country to country and
culturally in singapore is very
different to people working
in in sydney so so i guess
from the observations and the experience
from my perspective dealing with end
users
a lot of them have been quite quick to
reduce space to reduce costs
to provide flexibility but i agree with
richard totally that
when more vaccinations are being rolled
out when people feel safe
people feel that there's a need to be
socially integrated they will come back
to the office
uh maybe not 100 of the time so that's
why the fit out
the the spatial design will morph
into a an environment where
where it is conducive for people to
interact to have engagement dialogues
and stuff like that
as opposed to just coming back and set
your desk so that that i feel is going
to come back in a strong way
to the later part of 20 20 21 and moving
on to 22.
yeah maybe if i may at um
interesting that uh we just implemented
uh
what we call a contingency plan uh
segregation plan
group a group b from last
wednesday onwards and
it's difficult to make people work from
home
actually three weeks three months ago
was the opposite
in the beginning of the year when
government was a little bit more
releasing on the on the number of group
of people
then uh was difficult to boo the the
team back to to the office
so this is a big exercise i think one of
the points that he mentioned or she
mentioned
is about how you engage your team
to make sure that when you bring back to
the office it's still
for the ones that prefer to work more
from home to be still engaged
and feel comfortable and the opposite
happens the same that some of them
prefer to stay in the office because hey
see my my ac is not working properly at
home and
if i stay home my wife or my spouse
always has something that i cannot do it
and this and that
and then there are a lot of elements
that some people prefer to stay
in the office so i think this engagement
uh and
is a is a constant discussion with my hr
on how we engage and commit
our team to bring back or to make
a proper segregation but what i would
tell you is globally
we as a company we already adopted what
we call the
three plus two so three days working
from office
uh two days working from home is a
global standard for us
uh regardless the country and of course
always the government guideline of the
country supersede
our internal corporate guidelines so
that's how we
we have been practicing so far
thank you i think we've almost reached
the end of uh today's session
um i'm just checking to see if any other
questions there are still a few
but uh i think uh it's it's uh
thank you for for the guests
uh that's been here today sorry there's
one more question from the floor
oh sorry duncan yes i didn't see you
this is the last question um
are you finding that because it's going
to probably move to
i'm hearing this a lot two to three days
working
at the office um that you
you need a lot less uh floor space for
for your actual offices no point paying
crazy rents
if you don't need the space and people
are only coming in for two to three days
uh
a week and if that if that's the case
uh is there gonna be less need for so
much office space
here in in singapore and if that's the
case
what are you gonna do with the rest of
the rest of the space
yeah it's difficult for me to say about
singapore overall
but of course i can share my experience
of our office
where our office was already a flexible
office
so the capacity of the office was close
to
70 of our population so 1
300 people there but we had a capacity
of
800 900 people uh so it was already a
flexible office
in the in the first place and the second
thing is that there are some of the
global roles
or the regional roles that people was
working out of different place uh we
have a this is a
as a global company mnc we
defined the multi-hop approach so we had
a
hub in hong kong hub in singapore in
paris and boston and those four areas we
used to have
global teams around and some of the team
was running the
region of asia actually out of a
different place maybe from hong kong or
maybe from even paris
so recently uh we have to bring these
people to
close to the customer so to be honest
the number of employees not reducing
is even increasing but that doesn't mean
that we are taking more space because we
have a flexible office
right so that has been our experience uh
of course
every company has different different
situation and one another
topic that i i recently in the
co-working space company very big
co-working space company was telling me
that they are in the cdb and they are
telling me very clearly
is uh is increasing the demand is
increasing
they are having more and more customer
they are almost getting over capacity
themselves so i think there are there
are different cases
uh maybe uh somebody else want to take
in on the bigger perspective
um i mean this this question was asked
of me yesterday by another prominent
developer
and and they they wanted to know whether
if there's a reduction in area
requirements because of people changing
to 3-2
or 2-3 whichever ratio that they want
the trend right now it's a lot of
knee-jerk reaction
that we are seeing and primarily it's
down to cost
but there are a lot of companies as well
who are a bit more progressive
and they know that this is an interim
situation that they're in
and once things improve there is going
to be a demand for office space
um further down the track so
for now there will be some pain we will
see people
companies giving up space
it will probably create a situation
where reduce costs
reduce area when things improve then
they feel that they're
out of space you know and then they
start taking space from different floors
and non
continuous and stuff like that so that
presents another problem
as well so i think there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of conversations happening
between landlords and
and end users on flexi
workspace arrangements which uh stuff
that's been implemented by landlis and
c-suites
and there are a lot of providers out
there so increasingly there are a lot of
developers who are offering that flex
and core
arrangement to some of these users so
hopefully that could also be a solution
okay
it's coming to a close perhaps we
could have may provide us with some
closing thoughts
from ura's perspective or your own
personal perspective
as far as no turning back is concerned
on the issue
of hybrid working work from home and
and sustainability what are your closing
thoughts on this
i think actually you know we've been
talking a lot about
um digitalization and how that's uh
taking over
many aspects of the way we were used to
living our lives
but um maybe one thing that
stands out and it's clear that will not
move
i think maybe sharing more from a more
personal and
human perspective is that as human
beings
i think we all need social interaction
and we try for social attraction
despite all the you know faith
management measures that's been put in
place and
perhaps that's why people have also been
you know
not paying heed to it sometimes but it
fundamentally within what's come out of
the situation has also reinforced
the need for humans to interact with one
another
so when you talk about impact to
workspace design and even retail
experiences and all that
at the end of the day there is still
that you know experiential expect
that will remain very important and if
not
more so you know when we talk about
workplaces
it's no longer just a place for work but
it's also for collaboration for
interaction
but exchange of ideas team building
culture forming
likewise in neighborhoods i think the
the role of public spaces
will remain very important and even more
so again
as a community spaces for respite for
recreation but also for people to come
together
and to have that sense of being part of
a community
when we talk about retail as well you
know there's been a maybe
less of a demand for physical retail
stores but people are shifting to
experiential deep retail
right um what are the kind of
experiences you want to be in
please look at the citibank and also the
new ones the
wealth hub results i think the banking
experience it's an office in the garden
the kind of experience you offer so i
think
that to me is the interesting aspect of
all this you know despite
all the digital and the automation
i think it's the human you know
one-to-one
social interaction that will not be
replaced i think that's very important
for us to
still remember and i think that's very
important for us we think about you know
creating
livable and also lovable cities
thank you may with that allow me to
bring this session to a close
i would like to thank the audience over
here
for attending this session and the
online virtual audience who have downlin
thank you very much and
and last but not least to xiaomi from
uia
yoon from schneider electric and richard
payne from landleads thank you very much
for joining us today
[Applause]
thank you so much this was extremely
insightful
session thank you so much for coming and
for your time
well well i wish we could stay a bit
longer i can think of a few more
questions but anyway we have to go
soon um if you haven't already
do check the exhibition downstairs on
level one
which is called the office disrupted
before we
wrap everything up i would love to
call up our narita cheer
the co-founder and director of paper
space asia
please if you can come up and give some
remarks closing remarks thank you
[Applause]
thank you valentina um
wow five weeks just kind of blitzed by
that fast
and we are finally here uh the finish
line in sight
uh we seemed like yesterday when we just
launched the office disrupted with
confetti
and 50 people together and a great way
to
obviously conclude the the whole topic
uh and what the future holds for us
in the last course of the five weeks
we've received over 5000 visitors here
at the national design
center we're very proud to have hosted
a four panel series with an over 400
attendees
both physical and online and 40 client
engagements from the private
and public sector have come here clearly
this
topic is very much aligned to a lot of
you know top level top line thoughts
across individuals as well as
organizations it's been a whirlwind
for sure and it would not have been
possible
without our partners sponsors speakers
moderators and most importantly uh
supported
uh beyond all this from the design
singapore council
so thank you um amidst such
uncertain times we chose to boldly
experiment
with new formats while working within
safety regulations
conducted an exhibition try the webinar
try the physical plus online exhibition
and thank you richard payne for creating
another version of a possible hybrid
where you can bring a speaker
also a third dimension to it and if
there's one thing that a hybrid future
looks like
i think it's to constantly think about
or anticipate the unexpected
and just deal with it as it comes has
been the biggest takeaway
uh for me and the team we've heard and
we've been very privileged to hear
across
different expertise from different vast
fields
to kind of really look at the subject
matter across
so many uh spheres and as we kind of try
to think about new ways
of how working and our future life
will impact singapore's future landscape
how we individually look at work life
how organizations are going to embrace a
new future
um i think it's important to think about
it in four different perspectives right
what's driving the fourth industrial
revolution that's what steve called out
is this big change that technology and
perhaps the pandemic has brought about
so let's look first about business that
have had to change
and have to kind of move forward and in
that
how then do we bring our employees on
our workforce
to kind of grapple with that and move
along with that process
and then only circling back in terms of
understanding or redefining
the new purpose of the office as richard
says is not dead
but perhaps the purpose of it has
changed and i think that as you take
three steps backwards will then
certainly impact wider conversations
of developments urban planning but i
think what's really
uh really encouraging as we look forward
is the possibility
of a much more integrated um
importance of well-being i think that
has surfaced so
bright and and strong in all the
conversations and and perhaps
become a greater focus for all of us
um and really now whatever i think it's
a critical
call to think about the new generation
of workplaces
as work and our environment evolve
and how do we redesign them in a time
that's ever changing
so where would you like to be in this
conversation
how are we harnessing our imagination to
look
for new solutions and possibilities
how can we better practice values of
empathy
collaboration and empowerment as driving
forces of the office
of the future so let's remain nimble
and innovative as we pace towards
a hopeful tomorrow across industries
let's encourage each other to be on the
lookout
for opportunities in moments of crisis
and never hesitate to shift perspectives
and lead
change thank you everyone for joining us
in the last five weeks
and i'll hand this time now to valentina
to bring this to a close
[Applause]
thank you very much narita before we all
go
we would really appreciate if you could
take some time
oh sorry i'll take my mask off okay you
can hear me better
so before we all go would you please um
take some time to take a short survey
there is a qr code
to your left and to your right so to
your left is this
a quick survey and to to your right
is the uh the information about the
other programming
at the national design center
thank you so much again for your time
today
and have a very very lovely evening take
care bye